Hi This is Steve Kaufmann.
Today I am going to talk about
why listening is important.
How do we use “listening”
effectively as strategy for our studying.
If you like my channel, please subscribe.
Click the bell,
you’ll get the notification.
If you are listening to podcast
leave comments.
I would appreciate it
So if you’ve been watching my videos
Today’s theme is
“Listen” and “Read”
That is the key
Language is not in your mind
It needs to come inside your mind
That’s why you have to listen a lot
read a lot
Reading is also an essential thing
Take a look the bookshelf behind my back
Reading is a good thing
But listening, “Listening”
You can do it anytime
with this recent technology of MP3
there are so many variations of
interesting contents that
you can find and download
listen to it on the internet
We live in this great time
Wake up in the morning and
while preparing breakfast I listen to them
Now I am studying Arabic and Persian
Listening is so easy
You don’t need to prepare anything
Just pick up my iPhone
put AirPods and there we go
It’s done
But when I listen to it
I don’t understand everything
I understand 30% or 70% 60%
And there’s always some part
that I don’t understand
Since there is a part I don’t understand
I want to read
Makes me want to read
I search the part I couldn’t understand
the word you don’t know when you read
for example you don’t know the word
called ‘Link’ then I search “link” and save it
And I listen to it one more time
I understand little bit better than before
but sometimes still cannot understand
This is the process of studying
When you start studying new language
and you aren’t that good
Then you should repeatedly
listen to the same contents
I always do this process when I begin
Repeatedly listen to it
Let me explain one more time
What do we need for our brain is
“Repeat” and “New thing”
We need both of them
When you only repeat the same thing
Our brain gets tired and it’s not fun anymore
therefore you end up learning nothing
That’s why we need something new and fun
We give them to our brain
The important thing is while you are
listening and reading new content
Sometimes you should go back to the beginning
and repeatedly listen to the easiest one
Because you will have noticed that
you missed so many parts in the past
And after you listen and read
new and more difficult ones
You should go back to the beginning and
listen to the one
That you already have listened 30times
You listen to it one more time
while preparing breakfast
You’ll suddenly notice there’s a
structure of sentences and words
This 31time of listening would help to
use or understanding those sentences and words
That’s why we need variety of contents
This listening strategy is about repeating
The first 3,6month
You will get to understand new words
And then you should listen to the
same content over and over
The best way is using
mini stories from LingQ
Each stories using the same words
around 5times
Repeatedly using the same words
And you should listen to
each stories 20,30times
Don’t listen to all the stories at once
You should listen to them
like 12345 and then 123456
then 12345678 just like this
In the end you’ll end up listening to
each stories 30times
This way create the
connection inside our brain
But as I have explained
Only repeating would be boring for brain
It’s not fun and can not
remember effectively
That’s why
We need to challenge something new
Therefore learning strategy changes little
I listen to interesting content over and over
because of getting used to those
new words and sentences
So new content has new words
I don’t listen to those contents for studying
I listen to them because it’s interesting
While you enjoy listening and reading
Your level of language get
better and better without knowing
You listen to content for study
And when the number of
listening increases
Then you should move on to
new and interesting one and “ Listen and Read”
It can be series on Netflix
To enjoy it you do “ listen and read”
Overall your level of words increases
And sometimes you repeatedly
listen to something easy like Mini stories
This would be affective way of learning
When you listen
You don’t need to listen to it fully
This is impossible
One of good thing about listening is
You can do anytime anywhere
Therefore you can do while driving the car
Inside train, while washing dishes
That’s why you cannot concentrate 100%
But it’s OK
60% 70% 80% that’s enough
The funny thing is
Let’s say I sit down here
and concentrate on listening
I can’t
If I listen to it
while doing something
I can listen 60,70%
Sometimes thinking about
something else
and come back afterwards
That’s better
I sit down here and
listen to something for 5 min
Everybody aren’t the same
but I believe
Listening doesn’t mean
concentrating on it 100%
If you could concentrate 10,30,50%
The amount you did concentrate
would become part of you
So if you are beginner you should use
the strategy of enjoying and repeating
As number of listening session increasing
Then switch to something interesting
You should read if you couldn’t understand
Open your iPad and use LingQ to read
But you don’t need to
concentrate or understand 100%.
It’s like rain of words.
It’s all good when your brain gets wet
by shower of words.
So today’s topic was about “Listening“.
Thank you all for listening.